Les arbres sont chargés de symboles depuis
très, très longtemps.
C'est pas très précis pour une historienne,
mais, longtemps.
Et l'arbre auquel on va s'intéresser aujourd'hui
est particulièrement important dans la mythologie
nordique, puisque c'est juste l'arbre des
mondes, le centre du monde, le cœur de tout
ce qui est sacré pour les scandinaves.
La théorie la plus répandue sur son nom
donne la traduction du «destrier d'Odin».
Yggr est l'un des nombreux noms attribués
au dieu Odin, et signifie aussi «redoutable».
Le reste de son nom pourrait signifier gibet;
or, un gibet peut aussi être désigné comme
le «cheval du pendu», ce qui donne le
nom final de «cheval ou destrier d'Odin».
La raison de ce nom est que c'est en restant
neuf jours et neuf nuits pendu à une branche
de l'Yggdrasil qu'Odin aurait découvert le
sens des runes.
Il est généralement représenté comme un
if, ou parfois un frêne.
Son principal symbole est celui de la vie:
de ses branches, il s'étend à l'infini vers
l'espace, alors que ses racines pénètrent
dans la terre et relient les mondes entre
eux.
Venons-en à ces mondes, justement.
D'après les récits, l'Yggdrasil permet de
relier les neuf royaumes de la mythologie
nordique, puisque ces royaumes reposent sur
lui.
L'une de ses racines, la plus grosse, s'étend
vers Asgard, le royaume des dieux Ases.
Une autre, la plus noueuse, mène au Jotunheim:
le royaume des géants des glaces.
La troisième racine, la plus puissante, passe
au dessus du Niflheim, royaume des brumes
et des morts.
Il est aussi connu sous le nom de Nibelungen,
ou encore Helheim, bien qu'on les désigne
aussi parfois comme deux royaumes distincts.
Les autres royaumes sont Vanaheim, le royaume
des dieux Vanes; Alfheim, le royaume des
elfes clairs; Svartalfheim, le royaume des
elfes sombres; Midgard, le royaume des hommes;
et enfin le Muspelheim, le royaume du feu.
On trouve des mentions de l'Yggdrasil dans
différentes eddas poétiques du XIIIe siècle.
Dans le poème Völuspa, la prêtresse völva
dit se souvenir des temps anciens où l'Yggdrasil
n'était qu'une graine.
Puisqu'on parle des débuts de l'Yggdrasil,
allons directement à sa fin et au sort qui
l'attend durant le Ragnarök, la fin du monde
pour les scandinaves:
L'Yggdrasil tremble,
Le frêne qui se dresse.
Le vieil arbre grogne
Et le géant se libère.
Dans le poème Gylfaginning, il est décrit
comme le chef-lieu saint des dieux, où ces
derniers se réunissent chaque jour pour tenir
leur cour.
Un autre poème, que je vais conserver en
anglais pour ses rimes, est aussi récité
par
la völva:
Car l'Yggdrasil n'est pas qu'un arbre, mais
forme un tout avec les différentes sources
qui coulent entre ses racines.
La première source se trouve près du Niflheim,
et se nomme Hvergelmir.
Elle est gardée par un dragon, Nidhogg, qui
ronge perpétuellement la racine qui en sort.
La deuxième source se nomme la fontaine de
Mimir, et se trouve sous la racine qui mène
au Jotunheim.
Elle est gardée par la tête maintenue en
vie du dieu Mimir, doté d'une grande sagesse,
et on raconte que quiconque boit l'eau de
cette source avec la corne Gjallar obtiendra
lui aussi intelligence et sagesse: c'est
ce que fait Odin, mais il doit pour cela offrir
un de ses yeux en échange.
Enfin, la troisième source se nomme Urdr.
Elle se trouve sous la racine d'Asgard, et
c'est devant elle que les dieux se rassemblent
avant de franchir le Bifröst qui leur permet
de se rendre dans les autres royaumes.
Cette source est gardée par les Nornes, trois
femmes qui prennent soin de l'arbre en tirant
de l'eau chaque jour de la source pour la
mêler à la terre et en faire une boue fertile
dont elles enduisent le tronc de l'arbre.
Ces Nornes se nomment Urd, le passé, Vervandi,
le présent, et Skuld, le futur, et ont pour
autre rôle de fixer la durée de vie de tous.
On peut déjà constater les nombreuses vies
qui reposent sur l'arbre, mais ce ne sont
pas les seules: l'Yggdrasil abrite aussi
de nombreux animaux qui veillent à sa santé,
ou au contraire participent à la souffrance
qu'il endure.
Des serpents venimeux attaquent ses racines.
Des poulains sauvages dévorent ses bourgeons,
chacun essayant de l'empêcher de s'étendre.
La chèvre Heidrun et plusieurs cerfs vivent
aussi dans ses branches et se nourrissent
de ses feuilles, et deux cygnes se baignent
dans la source d'Urdr.
En tant qu'arbre de vie, il est toujours en
fleur et les gouttes de rosée qui tombent
de ses branches tombent sur Terre sous forme
de miel pour nourrir les abeilles.
Sur la plus haute branche se tient l'aigle
Vidofnir, et entre les yeux de cet aigle se
tient le faucon Vedffölnir.
A eux deux, ils surveillent le monde nuit
et jour.
Enfin, aux pieds de l'arbre vivent deux dragons
qui cherchent sa destruction: Nidhogg, que
j'ai déjà présenté, et Moin.
Tout le long de l'arbre court celui qui maintient
à la fois la cohésion et la discorde dans
cet univers: Ratatosk, l'écureuil, qui
n'a de cesse de monter jusqu'aux plus hautes
branches pour redescendre jusqu'aux racines
afin de provoquer un combat entre les rapaces,
au sommet, et les serpents et dragons qui
occupent les racines de l'arbre.
Il représente la discorde, la guerre, car
c'est ainsi que l'Yggdrasil représente pleinement
la vie: elle n'est pas synonyme de paix,
même si l'arbre cherche à la maintenir,
mais est aussi grouillante, soumise aux risques
de la
guerre
et de la mort.